in some games players do everything in
their power to avoid using certain
weapons or characters
because they're
just
well of course there are those who have
rummaged through the trash tears of
their respective esports and emerged
with riches that have made them into
legends but for the most part these
sorts of risky experiments
rarely go as planned soulcast has
already found another with the shot dart
they've also got the denial of the
pushback in the nano swarm gonna hold
them back even further and this map is
looking done well vikings have got to go
back to the drawing board on that we've
seen the first yoru come out here in
masters
and maybe the last based on how it uh
how it played out
thus the so-called meta reigns supreme
it's this rigid yet evolving reference
point that defines and shapes the
landscape of every sweaty competitive
scene it's a guiding light for those
seeking a clearer path to success and
even the thought of going against it can
result in knee-jerk derision
panda
panda
[Applause]
[Laughter]
now just because valorant is the new kid
on the block doesn't mean it's an
exception to the rule in fact it's a
game where the meta actually changes
quite frequently compared to other
esports and we've seen a number of
players who've shown that with the right
attitude and some creative thinking just
about any agent and any play style can
be viable i mean look people play dazner
if they're playing against them and the
guy still pulls it off like there's many
times where i've been in the game we
know it's [ __ ] annoying it's
you know tim you know what's happening
you're pushing into sight you're like
you see the cage coming in the flashing
like he's already six feet away from me
now with the shotgun i have to like
have to like back off from this angle
because there's one guy playing on an
xbox controller his pants off and a
sandwiching his other but what
complicates valorent further is the fact
that not just agents have to be balanced
but guns as well and while most players
are popping off with standard buys like
phantoms and vandals almost everyone
avoids the stinger because of how
garbage it is everyone that is except
for nathaniel scully leong
valorance smg abusing reina one trick
give me let me suck that
oh
marketplace
one enemy remaining if you want to come
with me oh sorry uh this guy's finger's
so good is that going that good what the
[ __ ] is that
[ __ ] call of duty gun no cap dude
if it's cold y'all
scully spent the better part of two
years climbing the upper echelons of n a
valorant using a gun that even mommy
sage couldn't love reyna one trick
stinger
he's uh
i don't even know words words don't
describe it but after riot nerfed it
into the ground he had to reinvent
himself he has like a good mind of the
game but i don't i don't think the
stinger is that good anymore so it's
probably like a uh not the best weapon
to use only so how is it that this
reyna abusing ranked superstar has
managed to stay relevant and competitive
even though the gun that defined his
play style has since become one of the
worst weapons in the game
and how has he both used and abused the
unpopular peashooter to build a
community on twitch
okay so before we dive into scully's
story i must ask that y'all lovely
valorent stans like the video subscribe
to the channel and turn on notifications
unless you play reina
and you're not you're not welcome in
these parts hey beautiful woman
we don't take kindly to your tabs around
here yeah skeeter she ain't hurting
nobody
alright so before he started terrorizing
your favorite radiant ronald's in solo
queue where did this 27 year old anime
obsessed stinger savant come from well
aside from living in indonesia for a
year of his life scully was born and
raised in los angeles where from a very
young age he was introduced to the
esport that would spark his later
obsession with valorant
i am talking of course
about guns the duel
was that that was that was too much
wasn't it would you believe me if i'd
said
starcraft go to all-stars counter-strike
the e-sport was counter-strike
again both my uncles
they both owned internet cafes back in
the day and i would just always hang out
there after school so like they stuck me
on um my first ever fps game
counter-strike back in 1999 and the
floodgates just opened from that point
on scully dipped his toes into nearly
every fps game known to man from combat
arms to soldier front to call of duty
and even overwatch ultimately scully
returned to counter-strike with the hope
of one day going pro he fought his way
through esea and even made it to maine
in his early 20s eventually scully lost
his hunger to grind counter-strike but
when riot released the beta for valrant
in april of 2020 he decided to give it a
try and it turned out to be exactly what
he was looking for the asian abilities
like it has
the
similarities of um like counter-strike
but with those like skills added to it
which made me kind of like intrigued
so
i was like why not now it might surprise
you but in the beginning scully didn't
actually play rayna because
well
she wasn't in the game yet
god i miss those days
so initially he found himself
insta-locking sage i felt like she was
like the easiest character to play she
had a self-heal so i would run around
like just battle stage it up all that
changed though when valorent was
officially released in june of 2020 and
alongside it
reyna for the blissfully unacquainted
reina is a dualist agent who relies on
getting kills in order to have an impact
some would consider her to be a selfish
character but aggressive players who are
confident enough to take on duels and
pop heads tend to thrive on her
especially since if popping heads isn't
your thing you can just body shot people
in the knee over and over again and then
walk away from a sloppy gunfight with
eight hp and then just heal up as if as
if nothing happened
ask me what i really think about reina
anyway as soon as scully locked eyes
with raina he came up with an idea to
help make a name for himself within
valrant's growing community before i
played um ballarat i did play apex
and i one tricked wraith and i ran
around with two r99s i
saw the similarities in reyna and wraith
and like the r99s with the stinger and i
was just like i just said like oh let's
let's give it a try and i just fell in
love with it from that point on scully
decided that he was going to brand
himself around reyna and the stinger and
in july of 2020 he began casually
streaming his exploits on twitch now in
the beginning scully was more or less
going live for fun but all of that
changed after he was randomly raided by
asu from that point on streaming became
scully's focus and as he sank more time
into valorant the community became aware
of his unique approach to the game
man why am i never ready for that [ __ ]
like i swear like i zoned out
oh it is skully man
i'm versus five stacks
a [ __ ] is weak just watch watch
this is there you're gonna follow me in
or what now these were the glory days
for skeleton
but for everybody else they were a
hellish fresh nightmare known as
the stinger meta
it was a time when the stinger cost a
meager thousand credits and what you got
for that thrifty price tag was a death
beam that boasted a ridiculous rate of
fire insane accuracy at range and
virtually non-existent recoil the
stinger offered so much bang for the
proverbial buck that it essentially made
buying much more expensive full-blown
rifles feel almost pointless even during
the early days of pro play it became
clear to everyone just how much of an
oppressive problem the stinger could be
i'm hoping at least that they can
provide it right here they're looking to
push immediately towards a main it
doesn't seem to be going their way again
tanner the action it begins so quickly
and it might end even quicker three
kills immediately for assad but while
everyone else was suffering at the hand
of this souped-up smg
scully
was thriving he was hopping from server
to server shredding teams to ribbons and
adding unsuspecting victims to his
personal highlight reel cementing
himself as valorance preeminent stinger
one trick
you cannot
outsting her
but as much as scully was enjoying
himself to no end in the eight months
following valorent's release
riot
would soon put an end to all of that
after openly admitting that the stinger
was in fact a problem riot began to
address it with patch 2.03 in february
of 2021 the nerfs included a price
increase from a thousand to 1100 credits
but more importantly both its rate of
fire and bullet spread were made
considerably worse making matters even
more difficult for scully was the fact
that reina also got nerfed but that
wasn't the end of it
sorry i'm trying to smile so much after
receiving increasing backlash from the
community for the obvious run and gun
problems that the game still had riot
dropped another update that annihilated
the walking and running accuracy of all
the smgs in valorant it didn't matter
that the stinger's price had been
dropped down to 950 credits its bite had
been so savagely dulled that it was but
a shadow of its former self now at this
point
most one tricks who'd essentially been
cut off at the knees by a patch would
probably consider changing weapons or
characters
but not scully
scully
saw an opportunity after they nerfed the
stinger i actually stopped using it for
a while because it was so like hard to
use but then i thought to myself like
what would separate myself with another
random main i kind of wanted to like
brand myself around the stinger so
that's why i picked it back up
instead of tucking tail and giving up on
his gimmick scully decided that in order
to remain among valoran's elite he'd
have to adapt his playstyle around the
changes now because the stinger had
become a situational pick at best it no
longer made sense for scully to run at
every round like he used to instead he
added some variety to his buys proving
that the stinger hadn't been a crutch
for him
take one line thanks
one enemy remained
but on top of expanding his actual
arsenal scully had to change his mindset
he couldn't just hold w without
reservation and fire at anything and
everything that moved like he used to i
guess i'd choose my battles like more
wisely now as opposed to just like white
swing everything and just try to like
laser someone from like
long long beyond like bind you know
one more
at this point the stinger had
essentially become a meme within the
valerian community like the bison and cs
go or the mozambique in apex legends the
type of weapon that provokes incredible
frustration and embarrassment among its
victims but where most people saw a joke
scully saw a tool for mental warfare
a way to let fools know
that they truly did not stand on his
level
what
i got
melted
that being said throughout all of this
if there's one thing that scully has
learned it is the importance of
compromise he's learned that in order to
stay amongst the upper echelon of
competitors one must not become a pest
that no one else wants to play with
solely because of a gimmick i understand
how they feel like i wouldn't want
someone buying like a gun that's not
really like made to like win against
rifles per se and although he has been
forced to adapt and evolve his play
style over the course of the past year
one thing has remained the same from the
moment he received that fateful raid
from asu scully has been on a quest to
grow as a creator on twitch and by
carving out a signature approach to the
game and literally broadcasting it to
the masses he's been able to do just
that i would like to like grow my
community even further i get a lot of
questions like hey like scully are you
gonna go pro and like yeah i've had
thoughts of it like five years ago but
like i'm 27 now i just want to like
build a community like a tight-knit
community and just be a people's person
you know
almost every day scully can be found
streaming live on twitch showcasing his
radiant gameplay
his interesting cosplays and
occasionally molding when things don't
go his way and with larger streamers
dropping by to help support him he's
become one of valorent's most
recognizable reinas
wait what wait
holy [ __ ]
yo thanks for the rain bro holy [ __ ] i
appreciate it guys
oh my god
dude this is this is legit the biggest
fight i've ever had in my life despite
grinding his way to the top of valoran's
rank system only to get nerfed by riot
scully has quite skillfully managed to
stay relevant his beloved stinger isn't
busted like it used to be but he's found
a way to make it work even at the
highest level
one enemy remaining jordan
spike down a
as silly as it might sound at the end of
the day valorent needs players like
scully creators who are willing to show
that the game can be played very
successfully without sacrificing
identity to him he's just playing the
game he loves the way he enjoys playing
it but he's also showing content
creators that they can blaze their own
trails all while helping valrant to
distance itself further from comparisons
with cs go without the likes of scully
challenging riot's vision for what
valorant is we might not find out what
else it can be and that's something
he'll keep reminding us of every time he
boots up his stream
[Music]
the greatest esport that never was it
could have been such a manger esport but
there is for sure a universe in which we
should do a video
on like literally called the greatest
esport that never was and we just don't
give a [ __ ] about viewership at all
that's what we'll do we'll do a gun to
the duel video yeah